hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game from round three of the
tata still 2021 uh in a game between ali
reza ferocia and david anton guiharro
uh it's uh the previous game we've shown
was way too complicated so i thought
best show another one today uh so you
know we get we we get uh some fun out of
it
so alireza has the white pieces like i
said and he opens with
d4 that we have knight f6 knight f3 d5
and alireza goes for bishop to f4
uh yes and now alvarez also placed the
london system
uh we have c5 by guiharro uh e3
and now knight to c6 we have knight beat
to d2
uh pre uh uh leaving the c3 square
unoccupied so you can always play c3 if
needed
c captures on d4 by uh david anton e
captures and now
bishop to f5 and here bishop to b5
developing the bishop pinning that
knight and rook the c8 and here
uh there are some games where knight the
e5 was played but here
c3 is a new move so already in this game
as of move eight we have a completely
new game uh so let's see what's
happening here
uh we have e6 uh and queen to e2 now
leaving the option of castling king's
side castling queen side maybe not
castling at all we'll see
uh knights to d7 uh and now h4 alireza
starts
attacking that king side he's expecting
bishop e7 and castles
we have asics pushing the bishop back
and the bishop to d3 now
captures on d3 queen captures and now
bishop to e7 and
like we've seen many times so far when
white goes uh for the
uh for the london system king to f1 like
we said king
f1 is the new castles so you want to
keep your king safe
but also have the option of having the
rook on the h file pushing that pawn and
maybe using it for for attacking
purposes
uh queen to b6 now going after the b2
pawn and here
it's very tricky because you're going
after the b2 pawn but if you defend the
b2 pawn
then you pretty much allow black to
trade queens because the queen and king
are on the same diagonal
so here all it is that goes for rook to
b1 and david anton immediately goes for
a queen trade so queen to b5 uh it
allows whites to double black's b
pawn uh but this is uh this is what
david anton went for so captures
captures and now
a3 and it seems like a very timid game
as the queen is already
off the board but you could not be more
wrong so
let's see what happens with h5 by black
preventing white from further expanding
here with with the g4
knight to b3 uh and now f6
strengthening that center at some point
black will want to play e5 and the bust
open the center
so rook to e1 covering the e file and
now king to f7
defending the pawn here and preparing to
bring the rook into the game
knight to c1 uh and now knight to fade
all knights are still in the game so you
have to put them on on optimal squares
to
for maximum damage knights to d3 and now
knight to g6 again keeping an eye on
that e5 square black still hopes for
to get that e5 in bishop back to g3 not
allowing knight
to capture it and not knight to a5 the
knight will come to c4
and it's going to be a very active
square for the black knight with king to
g1
now you have to castle artificially so
the other rook can also enter the game
uh we have knights to c4 and now uh rook
to e2
now this knight can now move as the b2
point is also defended by the rook
rook h back to e8 and now king to h2
now the rook can come into the game
bishop to f8 and now
rook h the e1 again putting a lot of
pressure on this pawn here
and now b6 uh so what do you do here
uh we have king back to g1 uh we have
rook to a8 and
bishop to f4 uh alireza checking to see
if uh
if david anton is maybe interested in
capturing that bishop
but he just ignores it rook back to c8
and now
g3 already is a preparing king to g2 to
pre
to improve his position a little bit
rook to c6
and now king to g2 uh we have bishop to
e7
and now knight the g1 not a lot of
active plans here basically both
both of them are just uh going after
that e5 square
uh but now alegressa has to try
something different he has the white
pieces and he is uh i i
i don't think it's a hundred points but
almost 100 points higher rated than
david anton
so of course he wants to push for
something more here uh we have bishop to
f8
uh and uh sorry uh bishop to f8 and now
knight the h3 biologist bishop back the
e7
knight back to g1 and david anton uh
happy with a draw
with the black pieces here but already
says uh no let's let's continue a little
bit more
knight to f3 bishop back to e7 uh david
anton says okay then uh play something
else
and alireza goes for something else he
plays king to h3 and now
he's gonna go for this very tricky g4
move and
here all hell will break loose as you'll
see
uh black keeps repeating moves rook to
a8 and now
bishop to c1 defending that pawn once
again
rook back to e8 and now finally g4
and now what does white get by doing
this we have h captures and g for king
captures
and now rook to h8 going after this h4
pawn and here
already pushes it to the h5 and this is
a
an incredibly tricky position uh where
david
needs to decide what to do whether to go
back with the knight or to maybe go for
this tricky
f5 move but you kind of never want to
play f5 you want to
what you want to do is you want to play
e5 is possible if possible knight to f5
if if it doesn't uh get bring you
advantage it's going to bring advantage
to white
because now it weakens all of these
squares and it's just
it looks ugly but it was possible but
it's very hard to
realize why we're going to show why
because after king to g3
yes you can capture the h5 pawn but now
b3
and this is now incredibly tricky uh
because if you move the knight for
example knight to c6
then you have a problem here a fork in
coming
knight to c knight to d to e5 check
captures captures and now black loses
the rook here
uh on c6 uh but it's only if after
b3 you move the knight but this is why
it's such a tricky line
here black needs to go bishop to d6
check and only after the king moves
now you move the now you move the knight
and now the bishop and knight are both
guarding the e5 square but now the rook
no longer guards the e6 pawn
so here white would capture on e6 you
would get knight h4
check captures captures and we would get
this position that's uh
very equal white does have both rooks
and the open e file
but the the dark square bishop here
covering all of these squares there's
not much for white to do here
so this was definitely in the position
for black but
incredibly hard to find so david anton
goes back knight to f8
and now knight to f4 bringing both of
the knights here to guard the g6 square
we have
rook uh bishop back to d8 and now
rook to h1 black just has to wait and
see what alireza will do
we have rook to g8 now with ideas of
pushing this pawn opening up the g
file so now knight to h4 keeping an eye
on the g6 square we have
bishop to c7 now attacking this knight
but of course alireza doesn't allow the
capture knight f to g6 and now
if you capture here it's uh it's a very
ugly thing to do for example if captures
captures with
czech king f8 you're going to move the
knight you're going to bring the rook to
h7 and it's going to be
a very difficult position uh for for
black to play
so instead david nathan goes knight to
d7
and now rook h rook h to e1 again going
after that uh
e file uh we have rook to e8 black does
the same and now
finally bishop to f4 uh offering a trade
of dark square bishops with bishop
captures on f4
knight captures on f4 and now rook to d6
uh asking white again how do you how do
you go for some sort of a breakthrough
here
and first alireza before going forward
goes backwards knight to h3 he doesn't
want to run into some
nice nasty checks because you're you're
in line of this check
uh the knight is in reach of the white
king so the king is much safer there
and only then will alireza try something
else knight back to f8 and now
knight f back to g6 and again a very
tricky position where again it's
incredibly uh risky to go for this
capture here because now after h
captures and g6 with
check uh what do you do here uh we're
going to show what happens because
it's very interesting if kink the e7
then you just run into
knight f5 check and you lose the
exchange and in this position uh very
likely the game
and if you don't go to e7 if you go to
f8 it's not much better
first you kick away the knight with b3
and after the knight moves and now you
run into knight to f5 and this is a very
very complicated position but it is
completely winning for white
knight cannot be captured because of
this but you're also
uh you also have some very sneaky ideas
of moving the king
rook to h1 and the rook the h8 checkmate
it's pretty crazy for example if if
black moves the rook as the rook is
under attack you're going to play king
g2 and now there really isn't all that
much you can do
if if rook to e7 you might even offer
the rook still rook to h1
goes after the checkmate and you have to
start running away king e8
you're gonna go rook h8 to check king d7
and now rook to a8 with the idea of rook
a7
check but also just going after the
knight on a3
and the position is now uh dead lost uh
if you if you capture the knight
then just rook a7 check rook and block
but now you're gonna capture everything
captures captures and captures and after
the king moves wherever it doesn't
really matter
you're just going to go rook captures on
g7 move the rook and
then easily checkmate the black king
so this is what happens again if the
knight is captured so of course
uh knight to h7 was played and now
alireza goes
f4 keeping an eye on that e5 square
strengthening that as this is kind of
the theme
of this game and also keeping an eye on
the g5 square not allowing this knight
any any tricks
so rook d back to d8 and now rook to g1
now already shifts the attention of both
rooks uh to the g
file knight to d6 and now rook e to g2
now if the knight moves uh then
the rook captures with deadly purpose so
uh you know you can't really allow that
even if something like an id495
check you pick up this you win this
black's position just falls apart
so here rook to g8 and now comes
knight to e7 and this this is possible
because the knight on h7
is undefended so again if you capture it
then again black's position just falls
apart captures captures characters you
lose the knight as well
and uh now it's just a very very easy
position to play for white
so instead after knight d7 we have
knight to g5 with
check david tries one last resort maybe
close the g file at least for the moment
uh but it doesn't help him all that much
f captures on g5 we have king captures
on e7 and now
g captures on f6 with check uh this pawn
is now also hanging so king captures and
now rook the g6 with check king of seven
and now knight to f3 preparing to kick
away the king even further
not a lot for black to do here rook dita
f8 was played but now
knight to e5 with check king is seven
and
only now rook captures on g7 with check
so for the last 20 moves this is what
alireza was planning
with rook captures rook recaptures with
check and now
king to f6 and now as the rook is
attacked alireza pushes h6
looks tricky as the pawn can be attacked
but it's not a problem rook to h8
and now now now the brilliant king the
g4
giving up the pawn but taking away these
squares from the black king
and this is just awesome rook captures
on h6 was played
but now feel free to pause the video and
win this game for alireza
in the quickest possible way well i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
uh unstoppable rook the d7
and also for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's a rook the d7
this is what alireza played and it was
in this position on move 61 that david
anton guihara resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so the knight is under attack the knight
will be lost and of course the knight
cannot move if you move the knight
whatever you do
rook goes back to f7 with checkmate
that's why i said that
uh a few moves back after this rook the
h8 was played attacking the pawn
king g4 incredibly strong because it
takes away these two squares away from
the black king and then everything else
is just super easy rook here and the
game over the knight has no squares or
you could continue but then you just
lose the knight and
you you're not gonna have much fun being
a piece down
uh so yeah uh really crazy game uh some
complications not as complicated as the
previous one so i thought maybe just
uh show a a nice simpler one to uh you
know
enjoy enjoy the day a bit more
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh there's one more game
where we'll be showing from round three
but we're gonna show that one tomorrow
and then we may check the standings uh i
would like to thank brian flynn
frank banner gerard homer uh thomas
bardoskas and vinicius pereira for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so uh thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day